go fishing was the one that got it I was
go fishing right here fishing let's go
go fishing some of these names go
fishing oh man ah well thank you for the
compliment crumbs all right let's go
Sicilian I think I need a granola bar I
think that will have a wonderful impact
on my voice a good impact all right all
right i think i need to actually take up
and earlier than usual like two minute
break and fuel up granola reach in reach
right into that variety pack and see
what comes out let's go we are in open
sicilian land and
it's vesna cop Sicilian better know what
you're doing I don't know a whole lot
about it I've said it before but if
you're gonna play five know what square
is weakened this one let's go pretty
sure night v8 is a move to and need to
be very timely now this is weird what's
going on with 83 what is it doing trying
to get in b4 b4 could be played if
before wanna be played right away
without the assistance of the a pond I
moved my night here because I eventually
want to play here do I kick this night
away notice the pawn structure and where
there exists majorities right now White
has a majority on the queenside 4 verses
3 and the exact opposite in favor of
black on the King side and that said
this c4 pond wall or the sea pond would
like to play the c-4 but if I insert a
six now the night is kicked back to c3
which is making the expansion a bit more
tricky to get in so having said that I
think a six is a good start let me make
sure this night will be obstructing the
sea pond and only then run forward with
my other stuff and what other stuff is
that
hmm i'd have five @h 496 okay well
night f5 night g6 what I want to go one
of these to do I wanted to do this no no
no no no no I think I like this square
right here no I think I like this square
yeah okay um I invested quite a bit of
time right there what why did I finally
say to myself you know I'm going to go
to g6 it was to keep in mind that this F
pond might be pushing soon after a
castle striking at this lead pot of mine
and let's go did my bishop really think
he was going to go somewhere else no so
I really shouldn't have thought for any
amount of seconds early on that one I
don't know that there's a big difference
between I mean just go with this right
away right no flexibility whoa okay now
this is a little bit scary my night is
going to get kicked around um a little
scary here this is also to stop Bishop
g5 and to kick my night away hmm well to
that I say take that pond I don't know
how good it is but I'm gonna give it a
shot okay
let's go that pod could be taken why did
I do that it was just a clearance giving
up a pond so that my night will have a
decent square I could play here and
Bishop here is pretty much forced
otherwise wouldn't be playing there
let's do this first
now what
I was really fearful of h6 that's uh I
really does compromise my King side
position that H pond of whites could
turn out to be a giant thorn I don't
want that no thorns don't hit me with
any thorns um thank you by the way to
mr. nerd swagger on Twitter for being a
continual retweet ER and this stream was
no exception so f5 ig4 there are others
by the way but that's the one that I
just saw jumping in right now how about
just castle and then this idea f5 f4 is
there any rush with kicking this night
away no let's go watch out for the
tricky Forks beware of the tricky Forks
oh this night is a good square the night
is going to the bishop is hit the king
is going to be in rough shape the e
files open that's an additional thing
that happened I cleared the e5 square
and now this right here this right here
let's go rookie you scared be very
scared fear the rook let's trade a
little bit ah who's run away scared now
it's me but for a good reason I just
want to get rid of these guys if these
guys go this king is going to be shaking
in his boots as you wearing boots anyhow
night here let's get rid of this guy
Bishop f5 is a follow up if there's
going to be Queen side castle and it
seems like that would be pretty likely
well let's do this I want to get here
let's get central because this pond
might be pushing down here and I maybe I
shouldn't have been so quick to do that
I was silly because this Bishop is
all good you know let's do this since
it's in a pin pin that Bishop and then
pivot right here my bishop is an idiot
look at him on f8 what is he doing piece
of garbage piece of garbage all right
let's get central your night you know
you want to get central and there's a
follow-up what I want to do this nights
gonna be challenged immediately could
feel it let's go here my bishop should
really do something else than sit right
here and stare at his own pond in this
pond right here what a future this guy
has what a lovely future man let's go
here 25 less than 25 I don't have a good
position we're castle in opposite sides
I'm looking to break through somehow
kill the king is the plan this guy have
officially devoted to just being a
defensive piece and I just dropped my
beep on Oh what can you do that's okay
though I get playing the beef I if it's
taken upon push I chop make sure the G
file does not open up whatever you do
don't let that open up ah hit that Queen
be scared be very scared right now this
Bishop is an excellent defender I want
to trade Queens I'm fearful of getting
beat up here at less than 20 this is
going to turn out to be a rat race let's
take that let's just trade queens please
let's just drag queens please let the
ladies come off here please i'm down to
ponds and these ponds are menacing ok
the best friend right here that's all i
have is my best friend right here time
that's it killa bishop
over here why did I do that let's try
this this is bad this is so bad take
that pond Oh Mouse slippers Mel slippers
everywhere I'm gonna take my bishop they
shouldn't have taken my bishop it's much
too easy to pre move now everything is
locked up over here can make a million
moves if you're accurate your mouse and
my mouse isn't the most accurate thing
around not the most accurate watch out
for a tricky stalemate oh go fish is
down on time but go fish beat me up in
every way except in the clock oh man
let's go back over this one because I'm
really questioning now what immediately
after this game actually during the game
I was already thinking wow my decision
to play my night to g6 not so sure about
that one anymore so immediately drawn to
that position in other words so let's
flip the board and look from White's
perspective here this vestnik I've
opened Sicilian now what a three okay I
did not have a good game here I or my
opponent outplayed me that's how I
should state it quit making excuses I
was outplayed here but I still think
that a three is not right now moves that
I have seen here and i think the ones
that are more common our c3 or c4 and I
think it's c4 just getting the majority
going a little bit more and allowing for
the Queen to come out to a 4 with really
annoying possibilities for example this
is a
I don't know how familiar you are with
this particular line but know this much
if you're if you're playing the black
side and your opponent goes for this
let's say you're playing this veteran
akov and there is this 95 move you
pretty much have to take otherwise
you're dead c7 is going to kill you
chop-chop now if you play the night here
and then c4 is played keep in mind the
following if you play a six year I think
losing and how tempting a move with that
being after see for how many of you on
the black side but maybe say you know
what I want to get that night out of
here let's play a six not so fast though
because the Queen comes out to a four
pins the pond to the rook and threatens
a deadly discovered check me that would
be a discovered checkmate threat night
here taking the pond or here and if the
Queen place to d7 there's night c7 check
the queen is pinned king d8 trade queens
the rook falls game over be aware of
this in other words that if c4 were
played here a six is no good however
after a three a six is playable by the
way I'm able to speak about this because
I've experienced it firsthand and I had
to deal with the Queen a for moving
there was just no good solution so I had
to fall flat on my face and you know
firsthand experience is what I'm getting
that so anyhow right here I think I
should do something different with this
this guy right here what what what a
life he has huh night g6 I like this
idea g3 h4 kicking them around how about
this I think night f5 is maybe better
night f5 maybe I could play the D for
one day I'm not having to worry about
getting kicked around with this age pond
getting thrown down here so I think that
this is maybe an improvement and I guess
I allow for maybe myself to fiend kettle
the bishop still if I'm playing to g6
that's totally out the window can forget
about fein kettering the bishop if the
night is going to be gone to g6 so I
think that this is another one I'd be
testing out in other words the f5 Square
and I'm really I'm really scared here I
don't want to play this because of
Bishop to e2 and I'm just dropping this
pawn and what else is there I and I
didn't want to go in reverse here this
is very annoying my opponent played a
very good game getting their pieces out
kicking my night away this Bishop is
wonderful this Bishop is the king and
right here another good decision a
decision to not trade pieces recognizing
what recognizing that white has a space
advantage and things are so much more
difficult for me if there's more pieces
on the board I I don't like this Bishop
what is he going to do if this rook
wants to see I have to tuck my bishop
back that's what I ended up doing this
was a really good move I like this it
shows a good understanding of the
position Knight c3 Queen up your castled
everything is wonderful you push these
pawns well and I simply shouldn't have
one it was just a time thing right just
be cautious of grabbing that pun it
works out to be okay but know that you
could be in some trouble there maybe if
you're not accurate in fact why not just
move forward with your own pond advances
who cares about the beep on just push
here I guess there's this and then okay
well i guess i could see either way but
anyhow I liked the decisions that were
made I really did the knight Knight c3
move in particular and this g3 h4 idea
very nice okay my opponent says thank
you so much you are welcome good game